we are thrilled to have here on the
program a man from such great films as
Shawshank Redemption and Mystic River
which earned him an Academy Award he is
one of the many celebrity actors and
actresses who are in the new film
written and directed by his son Jack
Henry Robbins Tim Robbins and Jack Henry
Robbins in the new film VHS which is in
theaters near you right now as well as
video-on-demand here together on the
program good to see you gentleman how
you got it thanks for being here nup
kids good to have you here you have
right in front of you the camera on
which you shot this it's a it was all
shot on a VHS camera VHS and beta cam my
god my bar mitzvah was shot on something
like that this is the real deal this is
the AG 455 right Panasonic if anyone
wants one we have seven of them now so
camera heavy it's about just I was about
to say you had to go search high and far
for something like that run yeah and
this was the old faithful this was this
one shot most of the movie okay didn't
see you legitimately would press like
play and record on it just to shoot it
we shot everything on actual tape I mean
it was such a process finding the right
tapes and everything but pretty much we
want it to be genuinely of the 80s no
magnets allowed on the set and being 53
tapes which was our the film Brian and
we didn't have time during the shooting
to transfer them said yeah Jack had a
freakout one night and spent three days
it was at the end of it I'm like have a
cold like you always do at the end of a
shoe of course and I just looked down
this box I was like oh my god like if
there's a flood or anything my movies
gone so we actually I just ate up for
three straight days and digitized
everything transferred onto digital and
sure of course but the look of it is you
know you can't get it without shooting
you can't it looks like again you know
cuz I used to do this too when I was a
kid I would pop a tape in and record
something and just crash recorded on
whatever was on the tape and it would
remove everything that was from it like
what kind of shows roots well
[Laughter]
[Music]
public access with the famed you
remember Robin bird he's from Jersey and
she had some interesting conversations
unlock quite an interviewer there was
she was exactly doing that so where did
you come up with the idea of Jack yes
those VHS is pretty much like it's about
a 12 year old kid who rewards over his
parents wedding tape okay ah so you're
watching the wedding tape get recorded
over yes and it's all his late night
television and all of the kind of
weirdness that you can finally night
along with his life and that kind of hid
his friends and stuff yes so it's kind
of like a view into this kid's brain
both humor
Scott Carey Kenny and Thomas Lennon from
Reno and one Thomas Lennon he's every
scene that he is in so laughs out loud
so funny funny how much of that was
scripted where it was just him laughing
she's so funny I mean it was about 50/50
for him like he's caught a QB sled post
in this film you know complicated
relationship with his Brockman there's
one that's Chris and Mike over there by
the way there's one scene in this in
this Amy and it's I mean III the films
that leap to mind that would be similar
like Kentucky Fried movie right where
it's just one kind of skit if you will
after another after another after
another and we hashed together in that
respect right yes but there's also this
quite moving part of it too which is
that this kid his parents are going
through a bad time and possibly gonna
get divorced so it's kind of you see the
world through this 12 year olds but also
you kind of start feeling his angst and
his his you know aim comedy that is well
I mean it is funny I mean again when one
of the late-night cable scenes that it
gets crashed into is a I guess a female
Bob Ross okay okay painting a landscape
of a mountain and then it gets a little
bit strange because they're aliens
spaceships are on the top left corner
and she starts to talk about the alien
spaceships and do you want to then
finish the and then and what's in the
bottom what's in it she's dunking on
Dennis Rodman in a very graphic
I think the line is there's moisture and
some of his it's sweat Kerri Kenney play
my gosh so where'd you choose Rodman
just because that's just a funny was
like okay if anyone's gonna have a
fantasy about a 90 or 80s late its
Dennis Rodman I mean he was dating
Madonna he's dressing in dresses right
there's something about Dennis Ross
there's something about that it's Robin
here and today we're you know with he's
in North Korea one second or he's on
ESPN the next is a thirty four thirty
it's kind of crazy you know there's also
the late-night conscious pornography's
that the 12-year old days including hot
winter the first american film about
global warming it's funny it's it's a
everybody should check it out VHS and i
have the VHS version of it sitting right
here and you were very kind to rewind it
as well oh yeah right in tier DVD player
now just remember you know it's kind of
crazy I got again Tim Robbins and Jack
Henry Robbins here I just would remember
when I would rent a movie I couldn't
choose one I literally would walk around
the blockbuster for like a half an hour
and I'd be you know I don't know why it
would take me forever to do this because
there were so many bad movies and you
were like there's got to be a good one
in here somewhere right pretty much and
then you find it is that oh no
we rented that somebody put the Box in
back on the wall and you open it up like
what it was honestly a terrible thing to
do in society would be to return the
tape box but no take you cannot leave
the box up on the wall just terrible
yeah that's not that's like a betrayal
of humanity exactly I got again Tim
Robbins a Jack Henry Robbins here on the
rich eyes
this is interesting I gleaned this
backstage tell everybody Jack who your
Godfather's whose you're gone fine
Oh Ron Shelton who is the writer of Bull
Durham the movie that made me exist I am
here because of that film so why not
have him as the godfather of your child
what is it like to have Ron Shelton as a
godfather I mean as I got older and
realized all the movies he had written
and directed I really I mean as I did
what he does right it really became over
resource and I really like the guy is
amazing okay lunch are not late late
afternoon very outside yeah drugs trying
to be a responsible adult with him I'm
looking forward to that other side of
him good that's that's all you need to
do for sure
how are you introduced to him to Bull
Durham how was that introduced to you uh
well I went to audition for Ron I did
really well and then the agent says you
did really well but you got to go
through and so I then I went out and met
Kevin and pitched through his threw the
ball around with him so okay so where I
want to make sure that you know people
could throw yeah and I played third base
never had pitched before decided to
learn all those mechanics and then I on
top of that I wanted to do a kind of
Fernando Valenzuela thing you know
rolling the eyes right which Ron was
like gala
yeah yeah yeah cuz you get a breathe
through your eyelids yeah yeah pretty
much so so the the catch that you had to
conduct in order to get the gig was with
Kevin Costner yes we're out at Warner
Brothers Studios out in the valley and a
lot outside a bungalow there yeah so
people are driving their golf carts
around you while you're trying to catch
with Kevin Costner and you know it was
like okay no don't break any windows
it's loose you're supposed to throw it
in any direction right there
you know who's written as a lefty right
and Ron decided that you know
he wanted me so turned into a right that
kind of ruined the movie though if only
he was a lefty that would have been
really taken to the next level you might
not exist you know did you think about
it you boil it all down the premium glad
you got the part I'm glad you memorize
your lines that day yeah Wow nuke
LaLoosh pass behind time right there
yeah I know yeah pretty much
flashback which film of yours do you get
the most from your filmography I am
Shawshank overall but if I'm gonna you
know ballpark its Bull Durham if you
know I'm in various places Mystic River
sometimes the players sometimes you know
there's a lot of different ones Jacob's
Ladder again oh do you get Bob Roberts I
do not I mean certainly in this day and
age I mean you kind of saw across the
steering wheel where everything was kind
of headed yes politically in this
country tried to warn ya that Bob
Roberts was coming with his guitar
that's right I know were you basing that
on anybody at the time I was basing it
on the idea that entertainment had was
kind of being co-opted by politics mm-hm
and you know I think the first
indication of that was when Reagan used
born in the USA as a campaign so right
Springsteen got pissed off about that
but but you know that was the tendency
of politics becoming showbiz had started
then then you know people weren't having
serious discussions anymore about issues
they were more just about surface since
then you know image and you know how did
I come off and you know how does it look
and all those salacious rumors and stuff
like that right yeah so you but you get
Shawshank the most right yes or do you
say that how many times have you seen
Shawshank Redemption jak3 that's about
it huh I couldn't force him to do it
anymore I have to
so you say I've seen it three times this
week
really it's always on and it's maybe the
most remote trot movie of all time
I just read that yesterday
what no yeah impossible they just did an
accounting I see what you're saying
those checks those checks at now you
know that I open up and I get CSI Miami
he gets uh my goodness Shawshank
Redemption for this man like that's your
movie man well Durman and shake or two
movies Bull Durham is a must wash before
any baseball season I guess for me you
know the lines of Bull Durham do you
have a favorite line that you remember
goes in the front big guy and I still
have those you know garter belt do you
have that where where's the garter belt
it's in storage somewhere I'm gonna
bring it out for a big auction some
would you do I mean we'll we'll help you
we'll help you all Georgie to your
Jersey and one of my jerseys is in the
Hall of Fame in Cooperstown that is so
damn cool man yeah I mean come on
Cooperstown what a dream that was that
was awesome and it's because there was
the 25th anniversary of it is that what
you guys all got back together or
something like that or thirty but that's
a whole other story and we don't need to
get into that but okay way before that
they had asked me if I would donate my
shirt right and so I gladly did proudly
did okay so which is your guys team
together with the New York Rangers of
epiha that you guys share together
father-son sports - New York Rangers New
York Mets Mets why the Mets well because
when I was 11 years old on my 11th
birthday the Mets were in the World
Series in 1969 sewed and I was in the
stadium with my grandmother so George
Thomas severs your guy growing yeah yeah
Jerry Koosman and all those dude Dolan
Ryan was on that team straight and when
I was 17 I got to see them lose Game six
Oh
but we caught up we caught that one
catch over the wall and then lost so
Carlos Beltran just didn't swing that
was amazing yeah I couldn't you know I
move on I got yeah I mean you could you
could have you know saved him the
trouble of being a met fan I mean I
can't give up on Beltran you know he
didn't yeah I didn't see that in Bull
Durham the sequel oh oh pretty much well
it's been fun having you on here thanks
so much for coming here that's your
pleasure like I said I've been a big fan
of yours for quite some time and I'm a
fan of your film this is this is a lot
of fun it was a lot of fun to watch VHS
again is in theaters select theaters now
and on video on demand you can check
that out at Tim Robbins here on
Instagram and at Jack Jack Henry Robbins
on Instagram as well there's Twitter
accounts that we don't have to go into
right now but good to see you thank you
for coming here
appreciate it you got it